Wouldn't it be great if everybody could be an artist?
If we could take our ideas and turn them into compelling images?
This technology allows us to create a smart paintbrush...
...so that if you wanted to create a new picture,...
...you can just draw the shapes of the objects that you want...
...and the neural network can then fill in all the details.
If we add a water feature, the network is able to add reflections,...
...not because we told it that, but because it learned it.
Or if we change the ground to be covered with snow,...
...then it knows that the sky also needs to be a different color.
I really think this technology is gonna be great for architects, designers,...
...people making virtual worlds to train robots and self-driving cars.
The real advance here is that we're able to synthesize images...
...with a lot more diversity and more fidelity than we are able to in the past.
I really think this technology is gonna be great for the dreamers of the world.